yeah we're happy you're here so jeremy
i'm really happy to be with you
and um we are going to be running
through some
tools as you might guess very quickly
and actively with you
um i'm broadcasting from my home
jeremy's in his home
here in shelter in place in california
um so
wanted to start we'll click through a
few slides but first by virtue of
introductions we
you know us we feel like we know you
already but i'll introduce my colleague
jeremy atley graduate of
uh ut loves barbecue
beautiful family with four daughters um
and
always a pleasure to work with and i've
worked with him for
um 10 years and we've done all kinds of
interesting things
hopefully you've had a chance to watch
our past uh webinar on
inspiration and that's something new
we'll be talking about in the course
we're really excited about as a as
another category to equip you
and um with that jeremy take it away
um so today what we want to do is we
want to introduce you to a couple of
updates to the tools that you learned
in the empathize and prototype course
and also introduce you to a couple of
tools to help you engage
this kind of work uh virtually so as
barry mentioned we're both
our home offices i'm in a nursery that's
been reimagined as a home office
and uh what we want to do is we want to
introduce a few tools but
just before we even get to the tools
themselves we thought it'd be worthwhile
to
frame what we're doing and why yeah we
always like to start with the
quote from our favorite two-time nobel
prize winner linus pauling
and the the premise is with all of this
work is
how to get to a lot of ideas at the core
of innovating
um and this uh
research that we've we've come to love
that we want to bring you up to speed on
which is some research bob sutton
uh did actually a while ago um with a
fellow andy hargen on where they
analyzed
what it takes to get products or
services into the market
and this is an image of the funnel um
and
it is a first column is the number of
ideas
the last column is the number of
commercial successes
and um what is what this shows you is
basically this core premise
all of this is about um generation and
generating a lot of material and the
tools will go in today we'll we'll cover
that as well
4 000 is the number of ideas 226 is the
number of things that must be prototyped
12 things is the number of offers that
are put in the market and two to three
are the number of commercial successes
so it just shows something we've talked
about over and over in our courses
the which always astounds me is the the
amount of material
you need to be willing to come up with
and generate to
um to get something innovative out into
the world
um we also if you need some bedtime
reading we hear that some people might
have some trouble sleeping in the times
of this
virus crisis um i don't know jeremy this
could be a side business
our our academic writing will put you to
sleep pretty quickly but it's got some
great material than what we just
discussed
about uh building this idea of a funnel
and at the core everything we're doing
with you today and we're excited to
share some new tools and techniques
particularly with empathy
but it's about building this funnel and
this resilience to generate a lot of
material
yeah the pdf download comes with a free
vial and dropper of hip seed oil so it's
sure to
put you into uh your your uh slumber
quickly
but in all seriousness there is this um
we think it's a really big idea to think
in terms of input
and practice and behavior because
creativity is we would say wrongly
associated with
or wrongly um overly emphasized
with output and what we know and what
the creative practitioners who
with whom we collaborate know is that
creativity is actually
a function of input and so shifting
one's definition from an output
orientation
to an input orientation is really
important and the input of
imagination and asking oneself if i'm if
i'm entering into a creative endeavor or
i'm hoping to generate
a volume of material like professor
clayvon just mentioned if i want to
generate that volume
what do i do to stimulate my imagination
what do i do to stimulate my thinking
and what the research is clear about is
that
imagination is triggered by unexpected
inputs
it's actually when you come up against
with some something that you weren't
expecting
that your imagination gets triggered you
think of johannes kepler
gazing into the night sky right in the
conventional paradigm at that time is
the sky is firmament
literally it is a substance and what
happens and kepler with that paradigm by
the way who founded the laws of
planetary motion
how he looked up at the firmament
and saw a shooting star and his question
was
why isn't it breaking right it
challenged his paradigm and the
unexpected input of seeing something
move in what was believed to be fixed
he was able to start to imagine and
wonder
and what we'd say and the word that we
like to use is this word
inspiration when you think about a
process
of deliberately seeking unexpected input
we call that inspiration it's something
that artists do it's something that
creative professionals do
designers musicians etc they're very
diligent about inspiration
but we know that this word is a little
bit of a
double-edged sword because for a lot of
people the word inspiration
conjures images of cheesy
posters hung in corporate hallways in
the 1980s and what we want to say is
that's not what we mean by inspiration
what we mean by inspiration is a
disciplined
practice of seeking unexpected input
i had the privilege of teaching a class
with a
grammy award-winning hip-hop artist last
year and he said something in our class
which really
struck with me we were teaching students
of some tools for in
for seeking inspiration and i just said
look
do you have any comments on inspiration
for the students
because some of the students were saying
why are we talking about inspiration
and he said this inspiration's a
discipline
and to me it's a really useful thing to
think about
do i have a practice for routinely
seeking out fresh inspiration routinely
seeking out
unexpected input and that's actually
what brings us to this design practice
what is design thinking it is one
of many ways and we think it's a
particularly compelling way
but it's a way to engage
in a process or a practice of seeking
inspiration
and what's design what design thinking
is really useful for
is the fact that we become explicit or
articulate about a couple of important
responsibilities of the innovator
one responsibility is not just solving
problems but actually
finding problems we're solving and
that's where the first part of the
design thinking process comes in
is actually framing the right questions
and then of course the second
responsibility of the innovator
is answering those questions or solving
those problems
you're very familiar obviously as
graduates of the empathizing prototype
course with these various
modes what we want to do in this session
is actually focus on this
empathize portion of the design thinking
process
and we want to share a couple of simple
tools that we've been using as we're
sheltering in place ourselves and
thought wow
we bet folks who've been through the
empathizing prototype course would
appreciate these things
the goal is still to provoke fresh
thinking
in the innovator and if you think about
your job as an innovator as
filling your funnel filled with ideas
you need routine practices to seek out
unexpected inputs and one of the very
best ways to seek out unexpected inputs
is talking to human beings who are
impacted by your product or service
yeah and we know you can't go to a hotel
right now right
the assignment is not not
valid so let's show you some new ways to
do that
so what we're going to do is we're
actually going to invite robin one of
the
one of the members of the scpd team
we're going to invite her
onto the stage now so to speak and perry
is going to lead an interview with her
live and what we want to do is show you
some simple tools that we've been using
digital tools and frameworks that will
help
us capture the rich unexpected
inputs that come from a user that come
from a customer
that might provoke us or stimulate our
thinking and our imaginations
in unexpected ways so the challenge that
we're going to undertake
together in the next you know 40 minutes
is humanizing the work from home
experience
all of us are wrestling with what does
it look like to work from home and so we
thought
it'd be an interesting challenge if if
as you recall the first responsibility
of the innovator
is to find the problem worth solving
what's the problem here
and we all know that our natural bias
we're thinking about solving our own
problems and we don't want to do that
because
that's not unexpected input so instead
we're going to introduce a simple tool
that we're going to use with robin which
is called a journey map
some of you may have seen it it's a very
simple tool i don't think it was a part
of the
the empathizing prototype course but the
basic idea is for
any given experience asking a user to
simply chart
their emotional progression through an
experience or a time period
is a useful way to begin to have a rich
empathetic conversation
i know what you're thinking right now
i don't have a piece of paper and even
if i did i'm not with my customer
jeremy what do i do i've got good news
for you
i've got great news for you we're going
to introduce a couple of simple tools
but first i'll have perry kick off the
conversation with robin and then what
you're going to see is
i'm actually going to show you a digital
tool that we're using
to real time capture some of the rich
and unexpected inputs
that flow out of an empathetic
conversation even while it's being
conducted
virtually yeah and we're going to dive
right in
i think it's more it's more exciting
that way i think and we'll at the end
unpack
what is the software how are we working
as a team
and um and show you sort of where all
this leads so with that
um robin welcome to the program hi thank
you for having me
um so robin um thanks for doing this
with us
um no pressure that there's just pretend
like there's not a hundred people
in the wings listening be yourself okay
i'm just gonna ask you about
um working from home okay
and what i'd like to do is begin with
you recalling
um maybe tell me about the
uh particularly bad day maybe the worst
day you can imagine
in recent memory but but if you have it
in your head
we i want to talk about the actual day
with you okay
so something that comes to mind as a as
a particularly
bad day or worst day in recent memory
working from home
yes i yes i have it
you and i having a conversation but i'm
trying to get a sense of your
your emotions from highs to lows as you
go through and i'll just sort of
interject with a few questions here and
there and we'll hear about
um this day you had so maybe
tell me when it started and maybe where
you were
from you know your your highest high to
your lowest low like give me a sense of
where you were
so working from home and shelter in
place
it's interesting because some days you
get up and you're like okay this is just
a normal day and i'm going to go about
my day and it's going to be fine and
some days you get up
and you don't want to do anything at
least i just don't
i just feel apathetic about the whole
thing but that doesn't matter
because when i open up my calendar it's
seven hours of zoom that day
and you just have to do it tell me about
a particular day
when you when you happen like which day
was this tell me about the day
so a few weeks ago on a tuesday so
i only have monday under my belt it's
tuesday which means i
get out of bed and i did
and you shop i shuffled into the kitchen
and
made some coffee which helped um
but i just had a big sense of apathy i
went through my meetings
my morning meetings so let's say i think
i had three that day
i went i went through my three meetings
i got to lunch time
and planning what you're gonna eat for
every meal
takes a serious emotional toll on me and
i don't know who else feels like this
but on this day especially
when i was kind of already over
everything it just felt like the worst
thing which sounds
you know because i'm sitting here right
now i feel okay about my day and i feel
good because we're here and this is fun
and we're interacting but on that day
when i was already feeling not great
deciding what i was going to eat for
lunch
just felt like to is too much i just
wanted to give up and say
why can't why can't we just order
something in or why can't we do this but
you know you go to the refrigerator and
you put something together that you're
going to eat and then you know you have
four more
hours of zoom that because it was a it
was a it's a long day so i have
specific days during the week that are
longer zoom days than other which means
you're i was spending a lot of energy on
the zoom meetings i was taking a lot of
information
in but i wasn't actually getting
anything done
that i had to get done i was just adding
more to my list because that's usually
what happens in a meeting
okay so keep going so you're through as
you go through those meetings where you
end up on the
emotional curve so i
did the survival shuffle which is
something that my track host used
track coach used to talk about in high
school where you had to run how long and
you just did the survival shuffle when
you
i got through it i took all the notes i
did all the things
but really what all i was thinking about
was getting
outside i am going to get through these
meetings and then i am going to get
outside
take a deep breath walk around work up a
sweat and that
usually and especially this day that was
really key for me
and tell me about getting so continue on
did you get outside
i did um i went outside i'm fortunate
because i live really close to campus
so i hopped on my bike and rode to
campus and
actually what i did is i just
stopped my bike as soon as i got to the
oval um on camp on stanford campus
and i laid down and i listened to a
podcast and i just let the sun shine on
me
and it it really was everything
wow that's amazing what an amazing day
to hear about um so
can i ask i'm gonna ask you a couple
things that i just wanna i've noticed
and i wanna follow up on may i interject
briefly yeah okay so what you're what
you're seeing
is you're seeing and i'm going to share
actually what i'm going to do is i'm
going to uh
pull this slide over what you're seeing
now
is basically the first part of an
empathetic conversation
where harry was because robin isn't able
to actually
write on the journey map harry and i
were using a journey map to real time
capture what robin was saying or as best
we could
using this simple application called
that we've been using called mural
anybody can use any application they
want
but the point is we're quickly
documenting the emotional trajectory and
taking some notes of key
phrases along the way and now appears at
a point where
if you look and i'll share my screen
again but if you look at what we've got
uh what we've got captured from the day
you can see we've actually got a pretty
uh pretty high amplitude experience here
between the low point of i'm not getting
anything done i'm just adding more to my
list
and the high point almost of laying down
in the sun
listening to a podcast in the oval
there's a pretty huge
amplitude and so what what perry's going
to do now is he's going to begin to
as you already know notice some things
that have stood out to him either key
quotes or expressions or changes in
direction
and then he's going to follow up on
those things and he's going to ask for a
little bit more
information and this is a very simple
way to think about the flow that we're
going through so perry
please continue yeah so robin um thanks
so much for this so i'm gonna dig into
right in the middle of the day or for my
take in the middle of the day it's just
the um the you had some amazing quotes
about
lunch okay and said something in fact
deciding what to eat for lunch was just
too much
yeah so tell me about that it was it was
clearly implied like things were kind of
in my sense migrating getting a little
bit better and then that was
i could just see in your face it was a
deflate like you just
even here you know weekly weeks or two
later
you felt just deflated yes i think
that's because
i think that's because this decision
needs to be made two to three times a
day
right anyway like any day good day bad
day that decision needs to be made
breakfast lunch and dinner because we're
all at home
right there isn't oh i'm gonna grab this
or i'm gonna do this and so
on that day when i was feeling taxed out
by all other decisions
figuring out what to eat for lunch even
though it's such a small thing
sometimes it's just the thing that tips
you over and that day
i was like no i can't i don't wanna i
did it of course i did it
right what am i not gonna eat but it
felt
like a lot which is silly to say but
also it did
yeah and contrast that a little bit you
had a comment about your your morning
coffee like the morning coffee was kind
of a little bit of a
of a kicker for you positive it is
my morning coffee is very sacred to me
um i used to live in italy and i have
brought good coffee habits back with me
to the united states we have a great
espresso machine i have my oat milk i
know what cup i'm gonna have there's not
a lot of decision making
process with my coffee i have it all
settled in
i know exactly what i like and it really
i just
go and i do it and it's also a ritual
for me
whereas lunch isn't necessarily a ritual
awesome um super interesting so thanks
and then um the other one i wanted to
talk about was
in the i'm going to take you to a maybe
a
darker place even but in the afternoon
you said i'm not getting more
done but i'm adding more to my list
yes tell me about that so the app that
afternoon
tuesdays are typically my busy day for
meetings um
and when you have meetings yes they're
necessary because we are good in the
team about having meetings that are
necessary but also it's not as if
you're working on what you already know
you need to do it's
um reporting on or collaborating which i
do like collaborating
but also it's it's not working on the
list you already have it just might be
adding some things to that list like oh
like good things that need to be done
but also
you know it's not any quiet time to work
and get some things done and so i
definitely survival shuffled through
that day
okay
survival shuffle tell us what does it
mean to survival shuffle
what does it look like what does it feel
like what are you thinking
tell us more um
for me it means i accept
where i am in my day and the energy that
i have
and i don't spend any time giving myself
a hard time about well you can get these
two emails out between this
meeting or you can do this i show up to
the best of my ability for myself and my
job and my team
but i also am not trying to
crack the sound barrier on what's going
on i'm just
doing my level best and is that
just following up further is that um is
that a like um
a mode you sh i mean it sounds like a
superhero mode are you
what do you what do you do is it always
a mode or is it just sometimes
triggered tell me was that the same in
the morning in the afternoon or was that
in the afternoon
you you had an active thought about that
yeah so in the morning it's i'm i do my
better
more creative work in the morning and so
if i get to about two or three in the
afternoon it's not really my time to
shine
but immediately for creativity something
so if i'm going to have a big meeting
that needs
um that needs me to really
brainstorm i can do it it's just more
challenging for me so if
i woke up that morning in shelter in
place and was already
feeling a little bit blonde a little bit
depleted then i
know that by 2 pm that afternoon which
happened on this day
right that i'm gonna have to work harder
to contribute to that creative
conversation that's going on in the
meeting and so
the survival shuffle is kind of letting
everything else
go that needs to be let go and i don't
need to expend more energy outside of
this is what is in front of me
this is what i need to be doing i'm
going to focus on that and i'm not going
to put more things on my plate
yep robin so this is amazing i just have
one last question
um can you tell us about another
time you experienced the survival
shuffle what's another time
you were aware of the fact you're doing
it and get as specific as possible if
you don't mind
so outside of shelter in place or inside
shelter in place
it could be either could be outside or
inside just another recent time where
you felt like
i'm in the midst of survival shuffle
again
for me it's typically tied with
um if it's if it's not like for sure
i think shelter in place is a very
obviously distinct and unique time
right in our lives um historically
speaking
survival shuffle will show up for me if
i didn't sleep well
the night before or i'm not getting
enough sleep or if i'm expending a lot
of energy so for example
when we run um last august for example
we ran this comes out top of mind
because we were just talking about this
yesterday
we were in a pretty intense program on
campus for two weeks in a row
so 10 days 10 business days and we have
54 participants for example
and that is a lot of bandwidth and
energy
and so when you get up on that eighth
day right
you know what needs to be done because
you've done it for the seven previous
days
but you're tired i was bone tired like
bone like i would go to hong kong home
after work and
there was no food there was no anything
there was just shower in bed
that is survival shuffle and that's okay
that's okay
but i also know when i need to take care
of myself and that means
just go to bed let's go to sleep okay
let's pause there because robin first of
all we could talk about this for a much
longer time but let's pause there
we say thank you so much for sharing
your story with us absolutely
thank you for having me and also thank
you so much for having me
i now have a new uh vocabulary my
lexicon which i didn't have before
thank you great you're welcome bye guys
thank you bye
thank you all right so we just had this
amazing conversation with robin
and what i want to just showcase really
quickly
is if we zoom out what we can see
is the various kinds of aspects of the
conversation and you see we put it here
on our mural
but you can see the the engage part of
the conversation
is the actual graph that we that perry
drew while
robin was speaking we noticed specific
things we're actually taking notes in
the yellow and pink and green
post-its mostly just for color variety
to be honest with you no i'm kidding
it's red can be bad green things are
getting better
and then when we follow up we change
post-its just so that later on in the
conversation later on when we're
reflecting on the conversation we can
remember
kind of the sequence of events and then
importantly
we ended the conversation by asking
about another time
the user in this case robin felt the way
that came out
we didn't know anything about the
survival shuffle
prior to this interaction we that it's
not a term
perry or i have ever used but it became
apparent in that conversation that
that's an important
part of the the work from home
experience for robin and a part an
important part of
our our uh responsibility if we're
considering how to humanize the work
from home experience
for robin that seems like something we
want to understand more about so that's
the reason
that we seek stories specifically about
that
at the end of the conversation so perry
is going to kind of do some
magic jiu jitsu
i'm doing if you see his face you know
like a
real consternation for a moment it's
because he's there's there's a lot he's
burning a lot of calories thinking over
there
yes yeah i work a lot together
underneath perry's face as he's making
his faces but i could let's put it that
way
so now we can show your spreadsheet face
jeremy's spreadsheet face
let's do it it gets ugly we'll do that
in the q a hopefully
so now we're back to this idea of
problem finding remember design thinking
is an exceptional
methodology for simeon for for
exposing ourselves to and connecting
ourselves to unexpected input
that is for the purpose of stimulating
our imaginations to fill that funnel the
exploration pump
so i want to talk for a moment about
define defining the problem statement
that we actually want to solve
and you know from your course that this
is a point of focus there's different
points in the design process where we're
flaring
and then there's other points we're
focusing this defined moment is a
particularly important moment of
focus and in order to do that we're
going to do a couple of things
one is we're going to reframe the
problem the the
broad problem we were thinking about
addressing is humanizing the work from
home experience
now we're going to reframe that and put
that in
language that's specific to robin and
then the second thing we'll probably do
that in a bunch of different ways we'll
try on a bunch of different ways
but the second thing we do is focus
meaning we choose
we choose one thing that we believe is
worth working on
and the importance of reframing the
problem is hard to
over emphasize because your frame
dictates a lot of what you see
and a lot of you know john dewey the
famous
american education reformers once said a
problem well put is
half solved and you know abe lincoln i
think he said if i had
some you know call it 10 hours to to uh
cut down a tree
i'd spend eight hours sharpening my axe
you know or something like that
but the point is if you've got the right
problem you're a long way
towards the solution already which is
why we care a lot about the frame
and it's at this point in the design
thinking process that we leverage what's
called
abductive reasoning or the process of
inference
meaning we don't just take a statement
at face value but we seek to extrapolate
some human meaning
beyond the statement that might serve as
an actionable
uh learning that we could that we could
begin to
ideate against so this is different from
a lot of organizations definitions of
insight because they often think about
insight
as the surprising data itself we'd say
that's not an insight it may be useful
information it may be unexpected that's
fine
but the insight is actually the team's
interpretation
of that surprising information and it's
not a deductive
process by which we say if a then b and
if b
then c therefore if a then c
right that's deduction inference
is the process of wondering abductive
reasoning is wondering it's less certain
it's less
sure and for this reason the the image
that we use
to describe how inference feels is
actually this
because we're making a leap we're not
certain that what we're saying is right
and we're almost playing the role of
more of a psychotherapist
we're imagining possible interpretations
of things some things we heard
for the express purpose of provoking our
own thinking
remember ultimately we're trying to fill
a funnel and it's not about getting it
right
in fact the funnel the vast majority of
things in the funnel are wrong
at this stage there's vast majority are
wrong at this stage vast majority are
wrong at this stage
so it's not about getting the right
thinking it's about creating a
volume of thinking that increases your
likelihood of finding the very low
probability outcome
and so we won't go into detail but you
remember the story of doug eats our dear
friend from ge
healthcare he's he came to one of the
earliest programs that the d school
offered there he is in the picture and
as you remember
he designed mri machines and in his
process of
bringing design thinking back to his
organization he discovered that children
in particular have a terrible experience
with um with the scan experience
and he ended up designing a pretty
amazing innovation
right called the adventure series the
adventure series transforms the exam
experience
leveraging a very very particular
insight
that doug arrived at what's interesting
is doug
had to make that same mario leap himself
if you think about this mario leap of
inference that we have to make in order
to arrive at a truly transformative
new product it's it requires that we see
something new and what doug saw as you
know is that
he saw that there was a sense in which a
child who was going through a
serious illness was missing something
from their life but importantly
it was his team's interpretation of that
surprise
that became the game-changing
realization that
the team interpreted their unexpected
data points as
what's really going on here is she feels
like illness sucks all the adventure out
of her life
and it was that reframe that enabled the
team to get to a really breakthrough
concept called the adventure series
so that mario leap is
what helps us think of new ideas that
maybe we never would have thought of
before
and the mario leap is really important
in fact it's so important
that you know the user empathy map that
we taught you
in the uh empathizing prototype course
we no longer use that tool
here's what we use instead what yeah can
you believe it
that's like exactly
you're getting the upgrade right now so
don't get upset don't be alarmed
design thinking continues to arrive and
everybody's like don't say that
yeah exactly pull the plug
but this is a simpler way to think about
abductive reasoning and provoking
yourself to interpretation
all you do is say what surprised us what
might that mean
what surprised us what might that mean
and in our experience and as we watch
innovators around the world trying to
use that two by two what do you just say
do you think
feel it's unnecessarily cumbersome
ultimately your goal is to arrive at
what we call a frame
or point of view as we called it in the
in the course
but ultimately your goal is to simply
say who we met who inspired our thinking
what surprised us about them what our
team's interpretation of that is
and then based on that interpretation
the objective
or aspiration or ambition what do we
think it would be game changing to do
so we'll quickly show you in our mural i
think perry will share a screen
and we'll quickly show you how we think
about doing that just on our
conversation that we just had with robin
and we'll show you kind of real time how
we work through it
awesome hold on one second let me get to
the shared screen
there we go
so i'm going to take you in now we this
is interesting we've been trading off
working on the mural right so this is
this interesting app that you could do
this many ways i could have a cam
looking at a piece of paper but this is
something we thought was interesting to
share
that we've used in a few classes so
um as you look at my screen i'm going to
zoom out for a second which always gives
me a little bit of vertigo
oh yeah there we go okay
um but essentially where we were is we
did the journey map over here
so there's all the notes and
great interview with robin awesome note
taking
i was leading the interview jeremy
jotted most of these notes there's
actual quotes
we we see the arc of that um interview
well i grabbed a couple things i grabbed
a few quotes
from a boring copy i was struck by this
thing about her morning coffee that she
said that was a positive point and then
i
got this interesting reference on the
follow-up about italy
which that was super interesting that
that was part of what made that positive
experience in
in my reflection on the interview um and
then
the other thing we had to do of course
the survival shuffle because that's
incredibly interesting and we followed
up on it um
you can not reference it yeah
um i moved those over and said okay for
me
these are the uh surprises i want to
cover
so i i grabbed literally these are
quotes
i did this survival shuffle
and then i've got to get outside direct
quote
the other two quotes i grouped together
because i wanted for you all to make
more sense of what what made this so
compelling to me is
in this morning of malaise and i'm only
a tuesday and all this stuff there was a
bright point early on the interview
which i saw a smile on her face during
which was
morning coffee made me feel better i
believe
one of us followed up on that and said
why and um
there was a comment about remembering
italy so i thought that was interesting
so jeremy talked about this leaping to
insights it's you know it's a simple way
to think about this
is actively inferring so
i did this by myself traditionally
jeremy and i
or if we're working with more people to
do this together to get more diverse
perspectives into the inference
oh yeah um so my the morning coffee made
me feel better remembering italy while
making my cup of coffee that was those
were the quotes i said
perhaps this could mean what what
motivates those quotes perhaps could be
for her um connecting a happy memory is
a tactic to make it through challenging
times
she never said that she said and she
never said oh i call up italy because it
helps me
you know manage the morning that was
something just came out so i i put that
together and said huh
i wonder if that's actually something
that's going on for robin
um the other thing i said could be
another guess is for her
a great memory can be called up to
transform a task
so the other idea is maybe it's more
active maybe she actually calls those
things up when she needs them
that'd be another one um i did then i'm
jumping down a line to show you the next
one i just i was just in i was an
inferring machine well jeremy was
talking about inferring
i was doing it so um but these are all
guesses i didn't go back to robin and
get her on the cell phone and say is
this what motivates you which you guys
know from
um from the course is not what you want
to do with if you're seeking insights
you're just you're taking guesses at the
motivation
so the other quote i did the survival
shuffle and then i've got to go get
outside
struck it struck both jeremy and we both
followed up on it um
for robin she can access extra energy if
she can see the end in sight
so that one i really cute on this
survival shuffle was definitely like
reserved boost power and in the
other example she gave true it was day
eight and it was i wondered there's
something about
seeing the end in sight that triggers
that ability to use that superpower
um and then i have a morning coffee uh i
have a morning coffee ritual for robin
a responsibility isn't a burden if it
requires no thought
so jeremy add another one right there so
what we want to do is you guys worked on
a
on a points of view we call them frames
now as we teach we think it's easier
language
the main reason for that change is um
it's just an easier word
we found to understand regardless of
where you are in the world
point of view tends to be a little bit
more confusing when translated
um but same idea so it drops into a
simple format
we met describe the person we're
surprised to notice it's going to be a
quote
from up above we're going to pull down
we wonder if this means
that's the leap of inference we're going
to put our inference there that's our
best guess
and then we're gonna talk about it would
be game changing what what given those
things
what would be interesting to to um do
for
uh robin so which ones which one are we
moving down jeremy
oh i was just i was playing through if i
if i pulled these
here we go got it i'm just playing
through an example basically
all right so
for so we it reads as a story right so
it's just it's stories fine
we met robin a professional
zooming through long and similar days
from home
we were surprised to notice she said i
have
a morning coffee ritual we wonder if
this means
for robin a responsibility isn't a
burden
if it requires no thought game changing
to
optimize monotonous lunch
responsibilities
cool so that's a frame of many
that we could build and you you were
with us before we could we could grab
you know the next one and we could move
it down
and we could do a new point of view
putting it right you know putting it
right next to it right on top and do an
entire
next point of view
and what's fun is and i'll show uh one
extra slide here so
if you're gonna stop sharing your screen
for a moment i'll show one slide
one thing that you can kind of do that's
pretty cool or maybe folks can see slide
in the screen at the same time i don't
know
but one thing that's really useful is if
you know what
good is or you know the definition of
good
you're able to start to assess the
various aspects of your frame and even
compare them with one another
so here we've got a simple frame
evaluation sheet where we say okay the
first
you know table stakes is does your frame
focus on a specific
first person and share relevant context
so robin yes a specific person a
professional
zooming through long and similar days at
home right
so i would say that's a pretty good uh
focus sometimes we see
we see frame start we met board
millennials who
are looking for purpose in their lives
right and the thing that's hard is
with design work you can't design
something for bored millennials it's
that's really hard right
so the more specificity the better the
next part
of the assessment is does your frame
present a truly surprising observation
or quote that provoked you to see a pain
point right
she said i have a morning coffee ritual
is that totally surprising
maybe not in the abstract but when she
was talking about
it's not painful unlike lunch coffee's
not painful because it's a ritual
it's it's pretty surprising in that
context right and then
does your frame offer an insight about
the person that is emotional and flows
logically wow so we wondered if for
robin or responsibility isn't a burden
if it requires no extra thought oh
that's emotional i'd say that's that's
unexpected in some sense right you get
the idea we could go
kind of quadrant by quadrant here and
evaluate the four aspects of our frame
and then we could compare our evaluation
of this frame versus another frame
versus another
and even better we could ask others to
contribute
and what we'd say here is getting
someone else's perspective
is an invaluable um
insight at this point because if
somebody who hasn't wasn't a part of
this conversation and who wasn't
uh a member of our team if we if
somebody
if we read this to someone and they go
yeah so what
we've probably failed right the point of
framing up a human-centered challenge is
that it's inspiring that it transfers
energy that it provokes fresh thinking
and if on an honest examination if
someone else comes and says
i'm not moved by that at all that's a
real or wow that the second one is way
more interesting to me than the first
one
that's a gift and we'd say it's
something that you cannot do
alone it's actually a social skill it
benefits from a conversation from
multiplicities of perspectives
and especially from perspectives beyond
your team and then lastly assessments
really important because it helps you
know what to do next
do we need to refine some of our
language about robin
do we need to move forward into
brainstorming
do we need to talk to a different kind
of user and see whether we're confident
that this
is the right direction to take right
depending on the assessment we get from
folks outside of our team
we're able to start to self-direct and
navigate
our efforts so that's the real beauty of
um comparing multiple frames together is
you can quickly understand
what you should do next
all right so maybe
yeah maybe just to zoom out one level
before we before we uh go to questions
remember your job is not the creative
output it's filling the funnel of input
and thinking about that that paradigm
shift is very important
your job as a leader as an innovator
isn't the final thing
it's filling the funnel full recognize
second that the funnel the scale of the
funnel to ultimately deliver
commercial success is likely an order of
magnitude larger
than you thought it was and then the
last thing
being deliberate about seeking
inspiration
is a critical aspect of filling a funnel
effectively and efficiently
and design thinking and interacting with
end customers is one
amazing way to gain inspiration but it's
not the only way
there's lots of other ways too and just
like the tools you learn in the
empathize and prototype course
teach you about gaining inspiration from
customers there's lots of other tools in
our new course
on innovation strategy which is all
about tools for gaining inspiration in
other ways so we hope that you will take
the responsibility seriously to fill the
funnel
and there and take the practice
seriously to be developing ways to seek
inspiration
so with that why don't we shift to
questions
sure so there's some some we covered um
along the way so love all the questions
please keep them coming as we
as we talk our goal is to again equip
you graduates with
more inspiration around of course this
this
working in this medium that many of you
are in right now that you you can't be
face to face and
um we found it super interesting and
challenging to shift
as well as i love some of the questions
about basic interview tactics
um which are awesome so maybe we'll dig
into some of the stuff that's
more about interview tactics first and
sort of by that i mean
how the interview actually worked what
we actually did
um and then there's some really great
sort of broader questions
so um first one is you had robin
describe her
worst day how do you choose the question
to start
the discussion would it be something
similar describe your worst best
experience with
x yeah we i mean the answer is one is we
try them out
so we we role play them on each other so
jeremy and i will say huh if we want to
talk about
best or worst experience do we want to
talk a bit about a meeting
do we want to talk about the day and
we'll sort of practice i get
well i'll pretend i'm you know
interviewing jeremy and say well let's
try this prompt out how does it work
do we get do we get the information we
need you know are there interesting
follow-on so you you prototype it and
try it
there is something about if i had more
time with robin i would like to
juxtapose
with the best as well i might have asked
her
and i had a journey map if you saw on
that thing we built one
maybe if we had time but it's just
there's about
i think we were on with her for maybe
between 10 and 15 minutes which
felt really fast um i would love to ask
a few more follow-ups but
um i would have if i had another 10
minutes i would have said
ramen tell me about a a spectacular day
working from home
you know and i think that would have
helped us unearth um
a whole different set of um things in
her life that are interesting to
to follow up on so great question uh
there's another question about
um uh body language and how do we
observe
body language one of the things we would
say is with two of us
while we're also monitoring you know
monitoring uh
um webinar chat and all that stuff
there's there's a certainly bandwidth
constraints not only for our internet
speeds and things like that but just
also for
what we can attend to we find that in a
virtual environment having a team of
three
or even four is really useful because
then
different people can be responsible for
different things for example one person
can be totally devoted to being present
and listening such that they're able to
continue to drive the conversation
forward
they're likely going to be unable to
remember much of the conversation if
they've been doing their job well
another person can be observing
the customer or the user's body language
to start to see when are they wincing
and specifically for cues
that they want to follow up on later
when you said this i noticed that you
did this
right so that's a person probably who
would go into the second seat of
interviewing after the initial interview
is over
that might be a great person because
they've been observing and they can
they can um attend to more of those
nonverbals
and then the third person is capturing
everything
writing things down and then maybe they
actually have the ability because they
have more of a comprehensive view of the
script
or the transcript so to speak of asking
deeper follow-up questions later
by that time the person who had been on
leading the conversation
may have had an opportunity to catch
their breath and order their thinking in
a way that drives the conversation in a
meaningful direction
but the point is having some role
clarity is really important and having
some
collaborators is important it's really
difficult even in person
to conduct interviews one-on-one you
might have noticed that whenever you
went to the hotel right trying to
engage with a human being and take notes
is really difficult
but if you've got a sidekick or a
partner in crime so to speak
all of a sudden um they can free you to
be present for the conversation you can
document
when you're in a digital medium we'd
recommend three or four people it's
probably a good
safe practice so that you harvest as
much of the qualitative information from
the conversation as possible
yeah i've got a i've got a great
question um
well they're all great first of all
thank you the questions are are
amazing um and it's actually really fun
to be
in this because you've all have
experience so the questions are
um terrific about sort of digging into
the tactics
this one i think is a is a great one an
important one to cover relative to
journey map and not something we
mentioned
so thank you whoever submitted this is
did you determine when to start or end
the journey map
i noticed that her copy experience was
beyond the scope
but valuable and were able to jump back
so
the idea of this this scope of if i had
said the journeymap
must start what's your first minute of
work robin great 9am
let's start from there because we're
we're only designing working from home
right
what's interesting um and this happened
um is that the scope of the coffee
i would say that's her private time yet
it to me was super interesting
to to design from and use so it's
it's out of the scope of what we wanted
to talk about yet incredibly valuable
fully agreed um we did a thing recently
with an airline a while ago from the
and they wanted to to do a their project
for a class i think the scoping of the
project was something like we really
want to
deal with the curb of the airport to
getting on the plane experience
okay so interesting so that's why it was
scoped and and i think the journey
mapper when you're using dreamweaver
literally like tell us about your
journey from the curved you know
and we we test it out and you know the
the folks we talked to at the airport
mean for when you guys can remember
traveling
um when do you start thinking about your
trip
well people started saying well um last
trip i took was thanksgiving so
i started talking to my family i don't
know maybe six months before and doing
research on tickets and checking out
websites
and all of a sudden we're just like whoa
whoa the journey map i remember we were
taping another line
and a piece of paper in front of getting
to the airport
because there was so much of the
experience that was so rich that was
before it so
the answer to that question is if i had
been more careful actually i might have
started the line
of almost midway because so many times i
can't tell you a user will say well but
actually
my experience of my day at work for
example started the night before when i
got an email from my boss
it's like oh i gotta i gotta have the
journey map start where they start so
the answer is
that line is is does not need to start
from nine to five and in your bound
so i'm glad you asked this i think i
drew it in such a way it may have felt
that
way um but it's follow the cut the
the user and wherever they want to start
that journey
you know go with them there um so a lot
of times
it does start long before the thing
you're designing it
so that's really a great question and a
great way to use the dream map is think
of it as an
infinite line wherever they want to
start wherever they want to end when you
ask them about whatever the experiences
you want to talk about
that's what you should cover there's
a couple of uh pretty simple questions
we can cover quickly
as well one is there's talk about
big data how do you integrate this kind
of rich but anecdotal information with
big data
one thing that we'd say is very simply
qualitative insights are a great way to
learn how to interrogate big data
big data is um
largely inaccessible until you have a
line of
inquiry and these kinds of rich
qualitative even anecdotal interactions
can equip you with some really great
questions to ask of your big data the
other one i wanted to mention briefly it
says
could you explain more why you didn't
use the user empathy map anymore
very simply it's unnecessarily
convoluted it requires
more processing on that tool
then is needed so at that time
when we were using that tool we would
say explicitly
you only can see what someone says and
do when they
what they think and feel you're already
inferring a little bit right
it's that's inferred so we're already
making one step of inference then we're
saying
now what are the insights infer beyond
your inference and you go
you know it's it's there's a very
tenuous you know it's like
the on the the branch of a tree it's
like i'm
pretty far out here it's starting to get
wobbly right
and it's because we're inferring on top
of inference on top of inference we just
said
really whether they say it a lot of
times people say and do things that
aren't relevant and we find teams
spending an inordinate amount of time
um filling these buckets because there
seems to be some use to filling the
bucket and that's just not true
ultimately the question is what
surprised you what was unexpected
that's really useful the stuff that
surprised you that you didn't know right
because it's about provoking your
imagination great it surprised you
what do you make of that effectively
that's what designers are doing
and what we're teaching is i'm thinking
we're trying to to simply convey the
tools that designers use
to approach creative problem solving and
really they're looking for
to be surprised and then they're
interpreting those surprises and
interesting and unexpected ways
in order to provoke their thinking and a
lot of it is implicit a lot of it is
automatic but basically it's
what's the surprise what are what is my
interpretation of that what are the
implications
if i can try that on in five seconds
and i can do a hundred of those
iterations great what you may as an end
customer or as the person who reads the
new york times article
you probably only ever hear about the
one chain that actually worked but the
reality is
there's a hundred or a thousand of those
chains that they tried on
and didn't make sense and for us
simplifying the tool
to it's a couple surprises and a handful
of interpretations
free people up to do more of the work
that we want them to be doing rather
than giving the busy work of just
filling this huge canvas full of
post-its when very few of them
have any bearing on the opportunity at
hand
yeah i think um there's a bunch of
questions thanks jeremy i think there's
a bunch
the answer is that's a um it's an
evolution
i would say it's it's an evolution of
the tool the principle behind
all of that is still the same about
inferring um
the a bunch of questions about
inspiration jeremy talked a bit about
that at the beginning
um i i text into the
packs on our team who does all the tech
and keeps all of this running and
and makes us look great to
put out there's a link to the webinar we
did i
you know in the in this time two weeks
ago i think um on
inspiration and a couple different
topics um and i think that'd be a great
place to start many of you are saying
tell me more about
there's some i think we go through a
whole bunch of different techniques and
tools
to seek inspirations and there was a
great response to it so many people
reaching out
through linkedin and asking more
questions and finding the tools valuable
regardless of
what you're doing in your in your
personal life your work life would have
you
so that would be a place i would i would
look for those
and then um at the atom guy there's
there was also one i love which is just
the basic interview question
is robin seemed a bit like an open book
um
how do you work with customers that are
not giving much information
um are there other leading questions you
we would use so i think
a lot of times one thing i would say
some people are a bit more open some
people are hard to get through
and um we we did a class uh
recently with i think we had 60 students
jeremy and i we did this interview with
this elderly
gentleman and it was about health care
for
older folks and it was just he was
nothing no
hard feelings he had he was really had a
tough time hearing
um and we wanted to move really quickly
or in front of this class and he kind of
he had a tough time understanding why am
i talking to you but there's always you
know it just was really really confusing
and then
very very hard to get more than one word
answers out of them
and to me it was a terrific moment where
we suddenly realized well this is a
great thing to teach which is
sometimes interviews are hard sometimes
people don't want to open up they don't
you can
open an ended question and you know
robin was ready to share
she's she wanted to talk about her day
and she wanted to share and it was it
was such a gift
um and that's awesome and sometimes
interviews take a lot more effort
and and pushing with questions and being
patient and asking why
and sometimes some interviews might
yield a lot of information
and some not as much and i think that's
okay and if we were to be working on
this
as a project and we wanted to
demonstrate really good design to you
we would actually say let's interview
three four or five people before we
start
going into define we do this to show you
this this tool and this technique of
working in a distance
but the other thing is we would have
interviewed more people we would we
would want some different kinds of
people and some of those interviews
might have been hard
people might not want to share as much
they might we might have gotten to
tough topics and i think as far as how
far you can go an interview
to me as far as the user wants to let
you into their life
we don't want to sometimes i'm more
careful not to put sort of
you know incredibly personal information
into those quotes or notes so that
that it never goes anywhere um but
at the same time if if it's emotional to
them i sort of respect that and say
that's really awesome they're they're
sharing this is gonna it's gonna make
the project
amazing and we'll be able to do better
design the more emotion
they're willing to share um so it's
really a question of
um working and being patient and
realizing
um some interviews are gonna be amazing
and it's just going to be
easy easy for something to open up and
you're going to have trouble almost
taking notes fast enough which jeremy
and behind the scenes were typing away
taking so many notes
and sometimes it's wow they almost
didn't need a notebook they're one-word
answers and it's really really hard to
to crack anything open
and just being honest about that is you
know that that
the interview perry mentioned is
actually one of my favorite um
interviews that i remember because it
was so
it was so honest it was so at one point
it is now we're in front of like
80 people it's happening live and at one
point he looked he looked at the
woman who was kind of helping him and
taking care of him he said are these
people
joking right now i mean he's just it was
so
the absolute you know most
undesirable outcome and yet it was great
and we were able to learn a lot and we
were able to have humility
about it and have a sense of humor about
it and it's part of the process
not everybody you talk to is going to be
an open book i would say
one thing just to compliment what perry
said is there's an element of trust
building
you can't just it's not like hey how are
you it's all about your first day at
work
right we know robin we have a good
relationship with her right
um and so when you're interacting with
folks who are strangers maybe you don't
know as well
or you're building a relationship with
it's worth investing time
in trust building and there are a bunch
of different ways to do that it's kind
of beyond the scope of this
of this webinar but it's certainly
important to build
trust to build a sense of care
reciprocity etc before you dive in
and sometimes that takes time
so anyway we're at time today i think
hopefully we'll share a
link to the other webinars so if you're
curious about the inspiration topic you
can
learn a lot more there and we are eager
to connect with you all
if you really want to dive into that
topic it's a it's a i would say an
exceptional
hands-on immersion into the topic so
we'd love to get your feedback there and
to see
the cool stuff you come up with as a
part of that class too
thanks and link has been shared with you
thanks pax for doing that
all right so we'll see you guys on the
internets
you